I have a very vivid memory
of my GP saying to me:
"You are mentally sick
and you have to accept help
to get better."
Hannah was a healthy
20-year-old psychology student
living at home with her family
when she started experiencing
flu-like symptoms.
I went to my GP
and I was kind of told
that viruses
will just generally go,
you just need to go home
and rest, take it easy.
Her GP thought
she had glandular fever.
Hannah was feeling very tired,
so the symptoms fitted.
But then she started
to develop changes
in her personality.
Soon after, Hannah lost
her ability to speak.
I had to ask my mum
to come in,
sit with me
and talk for me to the GP.
I would kind of write down
to my mum
what needed to be said.
Hannah was sent home
with antidepressants
and a referral
to a psychologist.
Her symptoms deteriorated,
and she was soon admitted
to a psychiatric hospital,
where she was given
antipsychotic medication.
She was seen by a psychiatrist,
who ordered an MRI scan.
During the scan, doctors found
a cyst on her brain
and sent her to A&E
for investigation.
When I got to A&E,
they reviewed the cyst
and said
I was probably born with it,
it probably had nothing to do
with the symptoms.
But what they did notice was
that my blood test showed
I was fighting
some sort of virus.
More tests followed,
and after three weeks,
the results came back,
and Hannah finally got
her diagnosis:
Anti-NMDA receptor
encephalitis.
It's an autoimmune form
of encephalitis,
which is the inflammation
of the brain.
According to
Professor Guy Leschziner,
having your physical symptoms
mistaken for a mental illness
is not uncommon.
We do occasionally
see individuals
with very severe psychosis
and behavioural change
in whom the initial diagnosis
is of a psychotic illness
like schizophrenia.
But actually,
over the course of days
or weeks
whilst they're in hospital,
it begins to be obvious
that actually
what is underlying
their condition
is one of these
autoimmune conditions.
It's been known
for more than a century
that damage to particular parts
of the brain
and things like tumours
can result in changes
in personality or behaviour.
But over
the last 20 years or so,
we've begun to recognise
that there are a number
of conditions
that have an immune basis,
whereby the immune system
attacks the brain
and causes changes
to the functioning
of that brain.
In Hannah's case,
it took several weeks
for doctors to recognise
that this was a serious
autoimmune condition
that required treatment
with very heavy-duty drugs.
I was moved
to neurology ward.
I was completely mute
and I had lost the ability
to dress myself,
wash myself, feed myself.
So I really was trapped
in my own body at this stage.
Hannah underwent
immunotherapy treatment
and had 13 plasma exchanges –
a process of filtering blood
before pumping it
back into her body.
Although the treatment
didn't work initially,
and her parents were told
by doctors
she probably didn't have
long to live,
after two weeks,
Hannah woke up.
Hannah, say "Dad".
Dad.
Over subsequent weeks,
she learnt to speak again
and walk again.
She says it was like learning
how to live again.
I look back at the person
before I got encephalitis,
and I don't really know her.
I just can't connect
with that person.
Five years on,
Hannah has mostly recovered,
though she is still
on immunotherapy treatment,
and that makes her
more vulnerable to infections
and could impact her fertility.
I wish GPs would know
more about encephalitis,
because they're the first point
of contact
for a lot of patients.
I wish my GP knew
more about it,
so she could direct me
to the right pathway.
If I was to think about all
the people who had encephalitis
and died
in psychiatric hospitals
or care homes,
I wouldn't be able to sleep
at night.
In Hannah's case,
a physical illness,
encephalitis, was mistaken
for mental illness.
But sometimes
it's the other way around.
We know that the connection
between body and mind
goes both ways.
Physical problems can result
in psychiatric symptoms,
but also psychological issues
can contribute
to physical disease.
Professor Leschziner
says he sees patients
who have symptoms
like seizures, paralysis
and numbness
with no obvious physical cause.
Some are eventually diagnosed
as having functional
neurological disorder,
or FND,
which is a problem
with how the brain receives
and sends information
to the rest of the body.
We don't fully understand
what causes these conditions.
It seems that anybody
can be vulnerable to changes
within the software
that defines
how our nervous systems work.
We know that there are
some risk factors.
So stress, anxiety, depression,
previous psychological trauma
in particular.
But ultimately,
anybody can develop
these functional
neurological disorders.
Globally,
hundreds of thousands of people
develop FND every year.
Conditions like FND
and the experiences of people
like Hannah
have led some doctors
to believe that we need
to stop thinking
of mental and physical health
as separate.
I think we need to move away
from defining diseases
or disorders
as of the body and of the mind.
We know that actually,
in almost all cases,
there are contributions
from both.
Even in conditions
that are thought to have
a pure physical basis,
we know that how people
interpret their symptoms
is important in terms of
defining their quality of life
and how severe they perceive
their symptoms to be.
So actually understanding that,
making sure
that everybody has access
to both physical
and psychological treatments
is really of utmost importance
for pretty much every condition
that is seen
by our healthcare systems,
and is important for everyone.